- [Sai] Hello, ladies and gentlemen,
thank you for joining us,
spending your time with
us today for a Code Talk.
If you're not familiar, a Code Talk is,
it's not a recorded session,
it's a live coding session.
Lucas and myself, we're gonna
be live coding for you today.
My name is Sai Vennam,
I'm a Principal Solutions
Architect with AWS.
- [Lucas] Hey folks, nice to meet you all.
I'm Lucas Duarte, a Principal
Solutions Architect here
at AWS as well.
- Yeah.
And today we're gonna talk
about how you can streamline
EKS operations with Agentic AI.
This is very much gonna be
an informal casual session.
We want to give you folks an opportunity
to ask questions at the end as well.
We're gonna be going back and forth.
Lucas and I, we've done
this a couple times before
and we're excited to run through
what we've built for you today.
Last year, we did a similar
session about using AI.
You know, this was before
the time of agents.
This is even before MCP
was getting popular.
So we built a lot of things from scratch.
This year, we leveraged tools
that are available out there
that make it even easier
to build really robust
troubleshooting agents from scratch.
So that's what we're
gonna talk about today.
But first, I think it's
important to understand
how the technology has progressed
from where we were last year,
maybe even two years ago,
to where we are today.
- But we're gonna-
- Go for it.
- [Lucas] Thanks.
But before we talk about that,
I just want to introduce to you folks,
a new member of our team, the Kube Agent.
So essentially right now,
we have an agent that can be responsible
to troubleshoot your clusters
and also to remediate some issues based on
root cause analysis
using MCP, using Agentic.
So what we're building
here is not just a LLM
and a chat bot, because that's too 2024.
What we're doing right now exactly,
building an AI agent
that can be your partner,
that can help you to
accelerate your troubleshooting
and actually reduce the meantime
to remediation of your issues.
So what we are trying to do
here is to empower network
and operation center engineers
so they can use those type
of tools to reduce the
meantime to remediation,
because we know that Kubernetes
are very spread out ecosystem.
So that's the idea that we have
for our session, right Sai?
- [Sai] Exactly.
And here's the thing,
we don't have anything running right now
because our setup is completely clean.
But we want to show you
what we're going to build,
just like a little bit
of what's possible with the technology.
- [Lucas] Jarred of the possible.
So here, if you can see, we
have a Slack channel, right?
The Slack channel,
it's where are we gonna receive
messages and everything.
And then we have two
terminal tabs right there.
One is running a memory agent.
Stick to that information to the end
because we're gonna build that up.
And the other one is that
Kubernetes specialist agent.
So what's going on right now is the agent
is looking today's Slack.
We have received an alert
using alert manager,
and by the time we have received an alert,
we have configured a troubleshooting agent
to identify that alert and start
to do troubleshooting
based on that information.
So if you can take a look,
we are saying monitoring
agent has been pending state
for over one minute.
And right now in the terminal tab,
we are doing the Agentic loop.
And we are gonna explain that
later in the presentation.
But right now we are doing
the Agentic loop to try
to fix the monitoring agent
problem that we saw earlier.
Now the agent is doing the loop,
executing the tools until is
able to find the last response.
So let's see why the monitoring
agent was actually stuck
in pending state for a long time.
So in this case, it's
finishing the troubleshooting,
doing the summary and soon enough,
we should be able to have a
solution here in our thread.
So of course, in this case,
we're not having any human in the loop.
We can have that later for
using GitHubs and everything.
But just for the sake of
the art of the possible,
what we're showing here is
that the agent got the
alert from alert manager.
It concluded run books
that we have available
in our vector database.
It fixed the issue by itself
because of the information
that we gave to the agent.
And as you can see here,
we have the issue resolved.
"Oh, Lucas, but is not too
dangerous to let the MCP
and the agent apply that stuff
in our production cluster?"
Of course it is.
That's just to show the
art of the possible,
but we could integrate that
with GitHubs and everything.
But that's for later in the presentation.
But that's essentially
what we're gonna be building today,
our new teammate.
- Yeah, perfect.
And of course, that was a recording.
We just wanted to show you
kind of what's possible, right?
Like these alert messages
that can automatically fire
in your Slack channel,
seeing that the agent
can pick those up quickly
and respond with contextual information.
And that's something important
that we're gonna dive
into is, you know,
we all know LLMs are just
as good as the amount
of context you're able to provide them,
and that's even more critical
for what we'll show today.
So realistically, again, I
love that it's not a chat bot.
That's right, 2024, we're going into 2026.
We wanna go beyond that.
It's not just a chat
bot. We want a teammate.
And you might just be thinking,
"Oh, well, you're just wrapping
chat messages in Slack."
It's still a chat bot.
By the end of today's session,
I think you'll believe me
that it's more than just a chat bot.
And we're gonna dive
into that in a bit here.
Last year we showed RAG,
this is Retrieval Augmented Generation.
It's important for us to understand this
'cause then you'll see how
far we were able to come
with Agentic architectures
over maybe simple RAG.
With any sort of RAG pipeline,
you have a massive set of source material.
And in this case it can
be like Kubernetes logs
and of course logs can
go into the megabytes,
gigabytes, terabytes, tons of data.
It would be crazy to store
all of that as raw data.
And you know, LLMs, they
understand in a different language.
It's embeddings, it's matrices.
And so, the first thing you
do with any sort of, kind of,
retrieval augmented generation
is you take that data source,
you chunk it up, you
put it into embeddings,
and you put it into a vector store.
So that was the first thing
that we did last year.
Then when the user asks a question,
we take that question and we first look
for any relevant context
in that vector store.
And so that's what you kind of see here
with the context over here
is you take that context
and you put it along with the embeddings
from the original search.
Then now that you have the context,
you pipe that into the original question
and you pass it into a
large language model.
So by the way, that embeddings model,
this is kinda like a lightweight model,
just to find the relevant context.
The large language model uses that context
plus the original prompt
gives you a response.
Let's just quickly cover what we did.
Chunk the logs into vector storage.
The user asks the question,
why is my app response time high?
You take the relevant context,
you pipe it in with the
original input, boom,
you pass it into like a bedrock LLM,
like a big agent, maybe Sonnet
or Haiku, whatever you want.
And you get a response.
- The problem with that is,
one, we are limited to
the context window, right?
RAG can be really intensive.
And also we're using right here
because the model itself
is limited to the amount
of training data that it was trained on.
So now we need to inject that custom data,
custom logs to be able to
do the troubleshooting.
But this was last year approach.
- [Sai] This was last year.
And there's actually one
more downside of this,
of, you know, that data
source chunking and storing
into the vector database.
We were doing that often, sure.
But maybe like once every
30 minutes, once every hour.
We weren't getting live
data from the cluster.
So if an engineer just deployed a pod
and they're troubleshooting it,
that data might not have been chunked
and stored into the Vector database yet.
- [Lucas] And if the issue
is happening right now,
how we are able to reduce
the meantime to remediation
if we don't have live data?
- Yeah.
And so what we saw last year was,
developers would find an issue,
they would go to the Kube cuddle,
they would run some
commands, get them data,
and then pass it into the LLM.
It's like a lot of manual back and forth
and context switching.
And really this is why agents are here
to kind of solve some of that.
Strands is an open source
SDK for building agents.
And it's a fundamental way
that we're gonna build the
agent from scratch today.
- [Lucas] Do anyone here
already using Strands agent
or have tested the Strands agent?
I see couple of hands raised.
It's gonna be good.
- Yeah. Perfect.
No, and we're gonna get
into why this is SDK is
so good for building agents.
They've really thought through
the different use cases
of what agents might need to do.
We're gonna start using some
of those things as well.
In addition,
we're starting to see
this trend in the industry
of not just building one massive
agent powered by one LLM,
but using smaller agents that
use the right LLM for the job.
And so look, really,
I don't wanna go too much
stepped into this architecture,
just know that when a
user prompts this agent,
that agent can use other agents,
it can use multiple LLM models,
it can talk directly to your AWS resources
and it can hook into MCP servers
and the way it communicates
and the prompts that the agent
uses to talk to one another.
That's all customizable.
And that's what we'll show you today
with a very basic first getting started
with a basic Strands architecture.
It's gonna be a Slack interface
that is reading chat messages
that passes it to an Orchestrator agent.
And the reason why we use
two agents here will be clear
in a bit, but we use an Orchestrator agent
that then route send message
to another agent that's able
to load information directly from the API,
directly from MCP.
And what you'll see is
that we pre-configured
that agent to do a couple
of things right off the bat.
So let's get into it.
We'll show the demo here.
So, again, don't have
anything running just yet
and if we wanted to, we can-
I'll actually just load up the ID
and we'll walk through
some of the basic elements
of the architecture.
Right off the bat,
I think this is the first
one that we want to see.
- Zoom in a little.
- Here.
Let's do that. Cool.
Hopefully folks can see that.
- Yeah.
- [Sai] Nice, I think
that's pretty big, right?
Right off the bat you can see,
we're importing the agent
capabilities from the Strands SDK.
This is all in Python by the way.
There's a lot of cookie
cutter boiler plate
that we have in here already
that I'll quickly walk through
that Orchestrator agent
that I talked about.
Essentially, it receives
messages from Slack
and it's able to do a
couple of things like,
right now, we configured it with one tool,
again, cookie cutter stuff.
We haven't really cooked up MCP yet.
It's not a very smart agent.
We just manually coded this one.
We say you have troubleshoot k8s, right?
So let's jump into that one.
And if we go into that,
essentially it'll open
this file right here.
This is our Kubernetes specialist.
Some hints here saying we
will connect it to MCP,
but it doesn't have MCP just yet so.
- Spoiler alert.
- Yeah, ignore that for now.
We've actually just configured
a couple of tools in here,
so oops, don't wanna do that.
A couple of tools here.
So describe pod, get pods,
and we've kind of manually
programmed these in.
We'll talk about how these
work in a second here.
We tell the agent to use
a specific, you know,
bedrock model ID that's
configured in some config settings
that we'll go through
here in just a second.
And a troubleshoot command.
This actually does the
troubleshooting itself.
Okay, let's go through some
of the properties that we've set up.
So I think the one interesting
one here was the Model ID.
So we're deciding to use
Claude 3 Sonnet for this one.
Kind of a relatively older model,
but perfectly good
enough for our use case.
We also have some other properties
in here like the AWS
Region, stuff for Slack,
that kind of thing.
There's a Slack handler.
I don't wanna get too much into this.
This is cookie cutter, boiler plate code.
It just takes messages from
Slack, guides it to the agent.
This stuff is really
well documented, I think.
Think we coded this using Kiro, right?
Just auto-generated this?
- Yeah,
I just send a prompt to Kiro
and actually Kiro code everything.
I didn't even touch the code
for the like handle
itself for the agent, yes.
- [Sai] Exactly.
And one last thing,
let's just look at the requirements file.
These are all the SDKs that are
and tools that are loaded.
And you'll see us use these
throughout, not that many here.
Fairly straightforward.
Some of the Strand's pieces,
MCP, that kind of thing.
Okay, should we do the first demo?
- [Lucas] I think so
let's do the first demo
and just remembering folks that the agent
that we have right now
doesn't have any access
to MCP capabilities.
So the only two that it has access to
is describe pods and get pods.
So what Sai is gonna do
now is send a question
to the agent requesting
information that we know
that the agent doesn't
have the capabilities for.
But it's gonna try the best
to respond in the best way as possible.
- [Sai] So I'm gonna-
Yeah, exactly.
I'm gonna ask it what namespace
are in my EKS cluster?
That's me, I'm Lucas.
- You're Lucas.
- [Sai] But let's quickly take a look
at the tools that we configured, right?
So if we look at the agent Orchestrator,
we actually only had configured
a couple of tools here.
Describe pod and get pod.
- That's it.
- [Sai] We didn't tell
it how to get namespaces.
We didn't, it doesn't know how to,
so it's gonna try its best.
And before I show you
what it responded with,
let's actually see how it kind of thought
through the process.
It doesn't know how to list namespaces.
So first it's gonna get pods
and based on that output,
it's gonna try and
intelligently figure out
what namespaces are.
Not great.
It actually doesn't figure
out all the namespaces.
It says there's three.
And if we look at the response,
you know, it says
there's three namespaces.
That's actually not true.
If we go to k9s, you know,
it's just a handy CLI tool
to let us see what's running
in our cluster.
You can see there's actually a lot more
than three namespaces.
So we wanna make it better.
And to do so, I think, maybe,
I'll very quickly
introduce a new capability
that we've just announced.
I think it was last week, right?
- Yeah.
- And that's-
- [Lucas] Two weeks ago. Two weeks ago.
- [Sai] Two weeks, two weeks.
It's the hosted EKS MCP server.
Essentially, instead of having
to launch the MCP server yourself
locally, we do it for you.
And so that means instead
of having to launch a proxy
and tunnel permissions and
run the MCP server yourself
and scale it-
- Run it locally,
handling two process, a lot of mess.
- [Sai] It's all in the cloud.
And essentially you just,
it leverages IAM so you can
identity access and permission.
So you can use that to
grant the right permissions
to the right set of people
who should be able to use it.
So let's use that.
And actually it's funny,
right up until two weeks ago,
we were doing the old way,
and as soon as this came out we thought,
"Hey, we can really simplify
the MCP configuration
for our live demo."
And we switched it over.
- And if you're using EKS,
if you have IAM permissions,
you can just use it with
your favorite code helper.
- [Sai] Exactly.
And so here's that new
architecture, right?
So that specialist agent,
you'll just notice there's one more box.
There's on the bottom left there,
the manually coded tools
that we had from before.
And then now with MCP.
So now this Specialist agent can decide
to use the MCP if it wanted to.
Let's take a look at how
we would configure that.
All right, we'll go back into Kiro-
- [Lucas] No need to, just switch the-
- [Sai] Oh yeah, hit the demo button.
Should be good. Perfect, thank you.
Alright, let's jump in here
and we're gonna go first
to the settings file
'cause we need a property
and a property that will
essentially just tell it,
"Hey, we want to enable
MCP," so we'll enable this,
again, just looks at the
environment variables
and then sets it.
And so now in the actual code,
we'll go to our Kubernetes specialist,
which again, remember from the PowerPoint
that we built this into
the Specialist itself.
So it knows the MCP exists.
First we'll need to actually
import the system libraries
from, you know,
so we import MCP
and this is essentially
just using standard IO
to talk to MCP.
It's a standard protocol for
working with MCP servers.
- [Lucas] And Strands too
already has a MCP client embedded
on it.
So you can make your
Strands agent be a client
of MCP hosted servers
or even local servers.
I mean, it's very, very few lines of code.
- [Sai] Exactly.
And so let me just get
the spacing here, right.
- [Lucas] I think you need
to align the self one,
all the way up.
- There we go.
Perfect. All right.
So essentially what this is doing,
if a MCP is enabled, talk
to the hosted MCP server.
Again, obviously this will
resolve to US West too
where we're running this demo.
That's a hosted MCP endpoint.
One thing that we had to do in the backend
was just set up the IAM role
so that this app can talk to MCP
and get the right info.
And that's basically it,
launch the standard IO client
and that should be good.
Let me save it.
Let me go back to the terminal here.
Kill the python process.
- [Lucas] We need to
add the deletion method
as well.
- Right, right.
- [Lucas] If you don't
add the deletion method,
the MCP, the connection
will be open forever.
And then we're gonna have a problem.
But since it's a live code session,
just remember inside to do that.
So we don't have that issue.
- [Sai] There we go. So
here's the cleanup step.
We're gonna make sure we
clean up after ourselves.
It's very important.
- Important.
- [Sai] Okay. All right.
We're gonna back here.
And again, I think you were
saying this earlier, Lucas,
but we're running this locally
and so it makes it easy for live demo.
So we're just gonna start it back up.
So I killed it and then
I'm starting it back up,
now with MCP.
And we should see an indicator
that MCP is being used now
because until then while we
had the library downloaded,
we weren't actually using it.
Of course, you'll remember right up here,
we import it, we added
some code to talk to MCP.
So now it's thinking through the process
and oh, here we go.
I think it's because I made it very big.
- [Lucas] Yeah, just click on top of it.
- [Sai] There we go. Perfect.
All right, well the spacing got messed up,
but you can see it.
It says-
- Trust us.
It's MCP.
(Sai chuckles)
- [Sai] We're doing it live.
Okay, perfect.
Python app is up, it's
listening for Slack messages.
And let's ask the exact
same question again.
That's me. I'm Lucas.
What namespace are in my EKS cluster?
And it's thinking and now it should,
you know, it's using the
trouble k8s method again
and it's using a tool
that I've never heard of.
We haven't coded this, list k8s resources.
We don't have that. It's not in our code.
- [Lucas] I haven't coded it.
- [Sai] And in fact it's
only in the read me right,
but in our documentation for MCP,
but we haven't coded this anywhere,
it's getting that tool
from the MCP server.
It talks to that hosted
endpoint and it tells our agent,
there's countless tools that it can use.
But it says for namespaces,
this is the perfect one to use.
List k8s resources,
it actually gets the
correct set of namespaces.
And now fingers crossed, I
go back to Slack, check it.
Boom. All right.
So that's the first step.
And just a few steps
you've seen that we're able
to make our bot that
much more intelligent.
It's able to pull anything
from our EKS cluster
that realistically-
- Imagine if we needed
to create every single tool
for every single possibility
of troubleshooting in our agent
and would be replicating
tools here and there.
So what I like to think as an
MCP almost got an API gated
that we can centralize the communication,
standardize the tools,
and then reuse those tools
across multiple different agents.
Soon enough we're gonna
be talking about how
to break monolithic agents
to micro agents for sure.
- [Sai] Yeah, yeah, exactly.
You know, I think the analogy
a lot of folks have heard
before for MCP is that
it's like the USB-C,
universal plug for integrations.
But I really see this as a solution
for like an exponentially
complicated problem.
Think about all the LLMs out there.
You probably use three or four yourself
and then you know all the
tools that it could talk to.
You know, maybe your emails,
maybe an EKS cluster, maybe
different AWS services.
So think about it.
So if you're trying to build
integrations for 10 LLMs
to talk to a hundred different tools,
10 times a hundred, that's
a lot of integrations.
MCP is just that integration layer.
So you build it once and all
your LLMs can talk to any
of the tools that are built.
Okay, so that, that takes it
from an exponential problem
to an O-N problem.
Perfect.
So we've added MCP,
our chat bot is that
much more intelligent.
But there's actually
one thing that I wanted
to show really quickly in Kiro,
the way that we're actually classifying
when we wanna respond to a message,
if we look in the prompts,
these are kind of the prompts
that we've configured,
essentially telling the
Orchestrator how to behave.
We have some for the Orchestrator,
we have some from the system prompt.
Basically, telling it its purpose in life.
This agent, you're here
to solve problems for us.
But we have this key words file
and essentially we use these for kind
of dumbly figuring out
when we should respond.
So essentially,
we should respond only when the
keywords are in the message.
And so if we asked it a
question like what version
is my EKS cluster?
It's actually not gonna say anything.
- [Lucas] I think closer is
actually gonna say something,
'cause it's on the keywords.
- Oh!
- That's right.
It's live demo.
Let's do it again.
- Let's do it again.
But if I asked it what
version of EKS am I running,
for example, it wouldn't
actually respond, right?
Because we have this
manually worded approach
for keywords and we wanna
be better, we wanna use AI,
we want to figure out when we
should respond to a message.
And that's because in Slack,
you might have engineers
talking to one another
and they might use one
of those keywords when
they didn't mean to.
We should find the intent of
what the message was about.
If an engineer is talking about a problem
and needs a solution, that's
when we should fire up our bot.
Otherwise, if engineers are
just talking about their weekend
or what they did, we
should kind of ignore that.
Keywords is one simple approach to that.
But let's use AI,
we're gonna expand our
architecture a little bit here.
- Didn't change.
- Oh, here we go.
Okay, so we're gonna
expand our architecture
and in the Orchestrator, we
wanna make it a bit more smart.
When a Slack message is received,
we're gonna use a
different LLM, Nova Micro,
to classify the message intent.
If it's for troubleshooting,
proceed, otherwise exit.
I think the analogy I like here
is you wouldn't put a PhD mathematician
to run your hotel check-in process, right?
It's overkill.
You don't need that level of intelligence,
you don't need that level of operations
to route people to the right rooms.
We want to use a more
lightweight, more efficient model.
In fact, because the Slack
bot responds or listens
to every single message in Slack,
you can see how that could
exponentially get more
and more expensive,
if we're not being a little
bit more intelligent about
when we respond.
And so that's exactly why we want
to use something like Nova Micro,
which is a very lightweight
model that responds very quickly
to respond to messages.
And so now, Lucas,
I'll pass it to you and he'll
show us how the magic is done.
- [Lucas] Alright, let's
take a look into the,
can you please switch to the terminal?
Awesome.
So let's take a look
into the should respond method real quick.
As you can see, if there is
any keyword that was defined
on that list that we just defined it here,
then we should respond.
So if you look at the list
of keywords that we have,
very limited amount of keywords.
So we have a limited validation
method that we just created.
So as Sai just said,
we want to do that in a much better way.
We want to be able to do
a smart classification.
So the first thing that I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna add a new
prompt for our classification
that model that we are using.
And then I'm calling that
classification prompt.
So if you look at this prompt,
it's very, very simple.
Is this message related
to Kubernetes, system
troubleshooting, technical issues,
or requests for help?
Then we pass the message,
then we're replacing
this variable right here
and I'm telling the model,
please just respond with yes or no.
Remember that we pay
by the amount of tokens
that gets generated.
So if we limit it,
the amount of tokens that
the model can generate
and still doing a smart classification,
should be good enough and
should be fast, right?
This is exactly what we're gonna validate.
So we have added a classification prompt.
Now I'm gonna go over
to Agent Orchestrator
and then adding some imports here.
Let me just remove that
import from line five
because we don't need that anymore.
So json, boto3,
and the most important thing
Before Invocation Event,
so Strand itself already
has the capabilities
of intercepting messages
before the message
actually hits the agent.
So what we're gonna do now is
we're gonna implement a method
that it's able to do a smart
classification using Novo Micro
before we send a message
to the agent itself.
So we don't even pay
for the Claude 3.7 model
that we're using on the agent.
So this is what we call
Before Invocation Event.
So before invocation,
the agent please run
this method right here.
What I'm gonna do now as well
is I'm gonna replace the
construction method here
with the one updated,
with the smart classification that we did.
So the only thing that is
different than the other one
is we are instantiating boto3 client,
just to be able to talk to bedrock
and do the Novo Smart classification.
The agent didn't change.
And then here, line 41 is
the most important thing.
So agent, hooks, add
callback, before invocation,
and then the method that I want to call.
The method that I want to
use to validate my message.
And I'm calling that method,
callback message validator.
Because it's very straightforward
name to my method.
What we're gonna do
now is, as you can see,
we don't have any method called
callback message validator,
any function like that.
So what we're gonna do now
is we're gonna create that function
and also the Nova classification function.
We're gonna go over
those methods real quick
so we can see what we are doing.
So callback message validator,
that's the method that's gonna be called.
Once we send a message to our agent,
then we're gonna trigger
classify with Nova method,
passing the message,
the last user message.
And if you go to classify with Nova,
this is where the trick
is happening, right?
So first we have the
classification prompt,
we are replacing the
message that was a variable
before with the current query
that we're sending to the agent.
And then here is the magic.
So max tokens 10 because yes
and no are less than 10 tokens.
So because we're limiting
the amount of tokens,
we are able to get a really fast response.
And because we're using Nova Micro,
we can get that even faster. It's fast.
- So the idea here-
- Some other models-
- [Sai] No, exactly.
And the idea here is, yes,
LLMs are non-deterministic.
You can ask it the same
question multiple times
and get a different response.
But there are ways you
can get around this.
- That's right.
- And that's exactly
what this is doing.
It's making that response
more deterministic.
Now we know that like 99.9% of the time,
I bet if you ask it this question,
it's gonna come back with either yes or no
and it'll likely come back
with that same response.
So really just routing exactly the logic
that that this goes through.
And of course less tokens
means faster response.
And since every Slack
message in the channel
will be sent here, it's gotta be fast.
- [Lucas] Yeah, imagine if we
have a channel with 500 people
and for every message to
classify with Claude 3.7 Sonnet,
it'd be really expensive.
So Nova Micro here could be one.
Another model that we tested was
on top a small language
model on top of CPU.
- That's right,
- We run that as well
on our local comp-
Like laptop. It worked.
Of course Nova Micro
is a little bit better,
but I mean if you have good enough CPUs,
you can also try to do it
with small language models
on top of CPU if you don't want
to use like Nova Micro and anything.
But going back to the code, return answer.
So if the answer that
the model returns is yes,
we should return true.
If it's different than yes,
then we're gonna return false.
And just one thing that I want to show
to you folks right here, line
53, message classification.
We're gonna look for
that information once we
test the new implementation
that we have done.
But before we do that,
we also need to remove that
method that we created before.
Yeah, so should respond.
And then this one you're
not using anymore.
So we are not using the keywords,
static keywords analysis anymore.
Now we are gonna rely a
hundred percent on Nova Micro
with the Before Invocation Event
that we have just defined
and let's see if it works.
- [Sai] And I actually like that better
that we're using this
Before Agent Invocation
rather than this manually
implemented callback approach.
You know, again, I've
mentioned this before,
but folks that built Strands,
really figured out all of
the things you might need
to do with an agent.
So before the LLM invocation
do this custom bit,
maybe after you want to do something
to format the message in a certain way,
these are all the kind
of things that we wanted
to show you what's possible.
Okay, so you're restarting the Python app.
- I've just restart-
- No errors.
- No errors, it's a live demo.
As you can see, it's completely live.
So if something breaks, it's my fault.
Alright, so what version
of EKS am I running?
I'm gonna send the same
query again to the model
and hopefully if everything works,
if we did it in the right way,
we should be able to a
smart classification,
then we should be able to see a response
because EKS again was
not on the keyword list.
So let's send it again.
- And so before-
- Message received.
Okay,
Generating response,
message classification.
There you go.
So if you look at this,
that's the log that I told you
and the content equals yes.
So before we didn't reply
because EKS was not there,
but now we are replying
because Nova decided to say yes
because it thinks that
this query is related
to system troubleshooting, Kubernetes,
information and everything.
So now, we did the classification
and we should be able to see
a response from the agent
that we didn't see before
because now we are doing
that smart classification
mechanism, right?
So as you can see here,
before we didn't have
this smart classification,
now we have these smart classification.
So let me just try to
ask something random.
- [Sai] Yeah, we should do
the negative use case, right?
Yeah, just for-
- Hey folks,
hopefully it works.
Hey folks, what time we are
going to have lunch today?
And then if we pray, there we go.
(Sai chuckles)
There we go, no.
All right, so-
- And you saw how quick
that came back too.
Yes, it's an API call,
but this model runs that
fast where you know,
and if we looked at the cost of it,
it's one token or maybe maybe
a few more for the processing,
but essentially yeah, output token one.
Exactly.
- Output token one.
So I mean that's how much we're
paying for every execution.
Again, if you don't wanna use bedrock,
if you wanna use your
small language model,
you can implement that same
architecture that we have done.
And as Sai said, I think
these Strands folks,
they have thought about
every single use case
that we could do.
We were doing these smart
classification in a different way
and Sai approached me and said,
"I think we already have that
before the callback
handler that you can use."
And then it was much easier
to implement actually.
But now, before we move any forward,
because if you look at the
summary of a recession,
there's an important concept
that we talk about, right Sai?
- [Sai] Yes, this is
something critical that,
and I think this is gonna be the crux
of what makes these agents so powerful
and it's this concept of tribal knowledge.
And I see this term being
coined in, of course,
the context of tribes
and software engineering
has been around for a while.
I kind of credit that to Spotify
and the Spotify model of
tribes and that kind of thing.
But essentially it's this
idea that the knowledge
that's in a company,
the knowledge, it's in
the hearts and minds
of the people that work there.
And these people are talking over email,
they're talking over Slack.
And there's actually a
really interesting case here,
an example I want to bring up,
have you folks heard of
the Voyager one probe?
The NASA, they sent it out in the 70s.
I'm seeing a few folks
nodding your heads, yeah.
Last year that Voyager probe had an issue,
the memory chip failed and it
wasn't submitting data back
to ground control in Houston and to solve-
- Houston, we have a problem.
- Yeah, we absolutely do.
And so the memory chip failed
and to solve this problem,
they had to bring up
documents from the 70s.
They actually went back
and pulled out cardboard boxes
full of old documentation.
And here's the crazy thing.
They pulled actual NASA
engineers out of retirement
to consult with to solve the problem.
And essentially with the minds
of the people along
with the documentation,
they were able to bypass that memory chip,
solve the issue and get data routing back
into their ground control
and all was good, right?
But that's a concept that we know
and we are all familiar with.
Even when you have perfect documentation,
well there really is no
such thing as perfect docs.
But even when you have
really deep documentation
and you have the folks that
are working there, you know,
you really have this
concept of tribal knowledge
that should be stored and it
should be present in the places
that your developers
are already operating.
And right now for a lot of our developers,
it's Slack or Teams or
wherever you're conversing.
And this is something that we wanted
to build into the agent.
Any time that an engineer talks
about a specific design choice they made,
or maybe a version of the image.
- [Lucas] A tip or like
how much you should define
for memory and CPU.
We know that it's not
really easy to define that.
- [Sai] Exactly.
And the thing is you shouldn't
have your superstars, right?
Your elite SREs constantly being bombarded
with pings of "Hey Frank,
like what was the version of
that image you were using?"
And look, we want all of us
to be as efficient as possible
in the workplace.
And so when these conversations
do happen, let's store them.
Let's store them in some
sort of knowledge database
that can be accessed when
that question inevitably comes
up three months down the line
or in NASA's case, 50
years down the line, right?
So we wanna store this type
of tribal knowledge somewhere
and to do so, we're gonna
expand our architecture a bit.
So this is what we had before.
And to add tribal knowledge,
we're gonna leverage an all new capability
that we announced back
in July, S3 vectors.
- [Lucas] So if you are thinking why they
are using two agents layer
on top of one another,
now you get a response
because you're integrating
multiple agents.
And if we have one,
all those use cases in a single agent,
trust me, I've tried,
it would took much more time
to respond in the right way
and hallucinate would
be a problem as well.
- Yeah, up until now
that Orchestrator agent
was just taking the message,
figuring out if it's relevant
and then passing it to the Specialist.
But now we actually have kind
of a branching approach of,
first we have to real think about,
is it actually for troubleshooting
or is this just a tip
that we should store away
for later use, right?
And the cool thing about this is,
the longer it's implemented
in your engineer's Slack channels
and wherever this agent is
listening, the smarter it gets.
It's storing these
solutions for future use.
Essentially anytime there's
some information being shared
in Slack,
automatically take it
and stored in Vectors
for a future recall.
Oh, and by the way, Vectors, again,
we talked about this quickly before,
but it's a type of database
that works nicely with LLMs.
Of course LLMs don't
think in terms of tokens,
they work with embeddings
and number matrices
and transformers.
And so vectors are very efficient way
of storing human readable text, right?
So you take a bunch of
human readable texts,
you encode it into embeddings
and then when the LLM needs to
scan through that data later,
it's a lot faster to go
through a vector database.
But then it's able to
kind of reverse engineer
that back into human readable text
and give it back to the end user.
So this is how we're gonna
expand the architecture
and let me pass it back to you Lucas to-
- [Lucas] And one thing
that I just wanna add
on what was said, Sai,
it's not either an agent or either an MCP,
it's more a combination of different tools
and capabilities to empower
the agent that you can use.
So, we're using MCP for
the live data, right?
So the data that we need in that time
that is happening right now in my cluster,
then we use MCP to do it.
But maybe some tips run
books and everything,
we can still rely on RAG.
We don't need to use MCP for that.
We could, but in this case we're using RAG
on top of another agent.
So it's a combination of everything.
It's not like if I use MCP or agents,
I'm not gonna use RAG anymore.
I think it's what is
best for your use case.
And every other essay probably would say,
it depends on the use case.
Yeah.
So let's try to implement
the memory agent right now.
Hopefully it's gonna work.
So the first thing, yeah,
the first thing that we're
gonna do is actually,
Sai told us that we're
using another agent.
So we created that memory
agent to be a standalone agent
because other agents could rely
on that memory agent as well.
So I've created a Kubernetes
Troubleshooting chat bot,
maybe, Sai's creating a database analytics
troubleshooting chat bot.
But we're saving and storing
the information maybe
in the same place and we
can reuse those run books
across multiple agents.
So the agent that we're
gonna be building now
has a server embedded
that's powered by Strands
and then we're gonna
integrate that agent server
with our current structure that we have,
Orchestrator plus Specialist using a2a.
And for those who don't know,
a2a is just a way to communicate
with different agents.
Json over HTP, essentially,
it's nothing more than that.
- Agent to Agent.
- [Lucas] Agent to agent. That's it.
Really easy to understand.
- So, Lucas, I gotta say man,
as you're going through that,
it sounds a whole lot
like the 12 factor app
microservices spiel that we heard,
what like 12, 13 years ago now,
in the early 2010s of
why we break monoliths
into microservices, it's really the same.
It's kind of this revolution,
it's this cycle of of programming
and it's the same reason why
we're breaking our agents apart
because look,
the memory agent has its own purpose
that might be used outside of
the context of the Slack bot.
- [Lucas] Just like a microservice, right?
What is a microservice?
Something that should do that
use case in a very good way.
And then if you want to add
other use cases on top of that,
then maybe we need to start
to think about creating
a different microservice.
So for the agent is
exactly the same thing.
The agent should have a purpose.
We tried to have everything
in a single agent.
The response was really, really awful.
Once we break it down
and then we used the
agent as tools pattern
with the Orchestrator agent,
we got a much better response
and performance on top
of the agents that we're developing.
So specialist agents,
that's what I wanna say.
So I just have pasted the code right here.
I'm gonna go over the
code that we are building,
again, it's yet another agent.
So it's just more of that other
code that we have running.
So we have the construction method,
we're declaring some variables,
just we are initializing boto3
clients to talk to our S3
as vector database.
And then we are defining a system prompt.
So essentially the system prompt
is what you are giving to the agent.
You should behave like that.
You are an agent that behaves like that.
So you are a Kubernetes
troubleshooting memory specialist
and then your role is store solutions
and retrieve solutions.
After that, it's all
like some fixes and send,
don't use mark down and everything.
But two main tools that we
have is the store and retrieve
and then using Strands, again,
we are defining the agent,
we are defining the model
that we want to use.
- [Sai] Lucas, I just wanna
point one quick thing out,
you look at number three
and some of you might be thinking,
"Only do what you do and nothing more."
It's very direct.
You might even consider it to be rude.
But we've seen official
research papers released on,
when you start using words like please
or asking nicely for agents,
they actually do end up
hallucinating more often
and not retrieving solutions
and responding the right way, so.
- [Lucas] And if you say please
you're gonna pay even more
for the tokens that we're
saying to the model, so.
- [Sai] Exactly.
So you do want to be very
direct with these models
and they behave better
when you give them
those tight bound lines.
- [Lucas] Try to imagine
that is a co-worker
that you don't like and be very bold.
Don't do that, don't do that.
Alright, so the agent
bedrock model ID, two tools,
I'm not gonna go over all those tools
but essentially, it's two tools only,
but I'm not gonna go over the code
because I don't have a lot of time.
So one tool is to store a solution.
What it does?
Store solutions in S3 vector database.
And the other tool is
to retrieve a solution
from Vector database based on a query-
- Lucas, a question.
- What?
- [Sai] We have to do the
conversion into embeddings
or does S3 do that for us?
How does that work?
- I was about to say that.
So S3 will not embed the data for you,
you're gonna need to embed the data.
So essentially embedding
is just make the data
in a way that the model can understand
and interpret that data
to respond back to you.
So for S3 vectors, it's
just a vector database.
We still need to do the embedding.
So in this case we're using Amazon Titan
on top of bedrock to do the embeddings.
And once we embed,
we cannot deem embed the
embedding data, right?
So what we need to do is
we need to embed the query
that we're using to retrieve.
So in this case the store,
let's go to retrieve,
we need to embed the data
that we're using to retrieve,
there we go.
And then once we embed the data
that we're using to retrieve,
we can search for the embeddings
because we cannot deem
embed the embedded query.
So we need to embed using the same model.
And because we're using the same model,
we can use that chunk of data to search
for similarities in our vector database.
- [Sai] That's exactly right.
And essentially, we talked about earlier,
you don't wanna store the
actual human readable text
'cause it takes a lot
longer to scan through it
and find relevant data.
It's just faster when you're embedding
and Lucas, how many LLMs
are we up to at this point?
Is that our fourth or I think
that might be the fifth.
We're using Sonnet.
We're using Nova Micro.
We used a different version of Sonnet for-
- [Lucas] Titan for embedding.
So far four different models.
- [Sai] Exactly and look,
like this is how LLMs
are meant to be used.
You pick the right one for the tool
and it's more efficient.
- In every agent
that we had there could
also use a different model.
We're just using the same
model for the purpose of,
I just want to export one
single environment variable.
But we could use different models
for different agents
with different purposes.
So for instance,
Claude Haiku is much faster
than Cloud Sonnet 3.7.
But it's not as smart
as Claude Sonnet 3.7.
So we need to do those balances
and try to pick the best
one for our use case.
But in this case we
have the memory server.
Again, we have two tools,
one, store and the other one, retrieve.
And now what we're gonna do
is we're gonna launch an agent server.
But before we do that,
I'm gonna actually try to
use those tools manually.
So what we're gonna do is
I'm gonna get the variable
that I have here from a class,
I'm gonna call agent and I'm
gonna say something like-
- [Sai] So this just invokes
the agent as if, you know,
if imagine the Orchestrator agent
was talking to the memory agent,
we're just simulating that
for the sake of testing.
And so we're calling the
agent directly and yeah, okay,
so we're doing a real example.
So Lucas is copying over at
a real model recommendation
that we have for the node exporter image.
- [Lucas] So what I'm saying
is anyone deploying monitoring
agent should use this image.
If you watched the hook
of our presentation,
you probably know where we are going
with that information, right?
So what we are doing now
is we're triggering it manually first.
So hopefully this query right here
is gonna trigger the store
and then we want to create another query,
another agent invocation
to retrieve the solution.
So what I'm gonna say here
is what node exporter image should I use?
- [Sai] And these runs synchronously?
So one after the other.
- That's it.
- It'll give it time
to store the solution.
- Yeah.
So essentially the first one,
we are not telling which tool to use
but because we are using an agent,
it should use the store
and the other one should use the retrieve.
So what we're gonna do now
is I'm gonna go to the folder
where we have that agent created.
There you go. So we have
the memory agent server.
- [Sai] And you can already
notice the difference here.
Before we were just restarting
that one Python application,
which had the Orchestrator
and the the Specialist agent.
Now we have a separate memory
agent that lives separately.
So it is its own microservice.
Lucas, you came up with
a word for this earlier.
- Micro agent?
- Micro agent.
You heard it here first folks.
And so look by the way,
we do give you helm charts
to deploy all of this
and all the sample code as well.
We'll share with you at the end.
So you could deploy this
in a Kubernetes cluster.
So you're not doing it manually locally,
I think it's just for
the sake of the demo,
we're doing-
- Yeah,
we are doing it locally because
it's a live code session
but it's all abstracted into helm chart.
So if you just wanna take the shot
and deploy this architecture, you can,
we're gonna give access to the sample code
for you at the end.
But going back to what we are
doing, let's try to see Sai,
if the tools are gonna be able
to be executed in the right way.
So we are hoping to get store
and then retrieve the node exporter chip.
So I just triggered the memory agent.
- [Sai] And you commented that out
so that the server isn't starting.
- [Lucas] No.
- [Sai] We're just calling
the agent synchronously,
just to test.
- Yeah,
so the first two store
solution, key information,
problem team, uses
inconsistent corrected image.
That's the image that you should use.
And then for the second tool
to retrieve the information, there you go.
So the DevOps recommendation is that one,
that is the one that
we added into the code.
So now we have that information,
our S3 vector database.
So what I'm gonna do now is
I'm gonna go to a dashboard
that of course was
completely generated by AI
and then I'm gonna refresh it
and then we should be able
to see another solution
that dashboard is just seeing,
it's just requiring S3
to check the solutions
we have available on S3.
But as you can see,
we have a total of one solution
in that particular bucket.
If I search here for NodeExporter,
we should be able to see the solution
that we just persisted.
So Teams is inconsistent
or incorrect image
for Node Exporter in Kubernetes
monitoring deployments.
That's the image that you should use.
So we have that in the
vector database right now
because we tested
locally our memory agent.
So what we're gonna do now
is we're gonna remove
those local executions
that we have just done and
then we're gonna now, yes,
start the a2a server.
So if you look at here
we have the a2a server
that is essentially a library
that we have imported from
Strand multi-agent capabilities.
We're passing the agent that
we wanna run as a server
and then we do a serve.
Behind the scenes, it's gonna
start a uvicorn process.
So if you do python
memory agent server.py,
now we have agent running as a server.
So if it's running as a server,
you can expose to a load balancer
and now you can use that
agent with your other agent.
So you don't need to replicate
that memory agent code
again and again and again.
So that's it for now for
the memory agent server.
Now what we're gonna do is we need
to make the Orchestrator agent communicate
to the memory agent server, right?
And for that we're using a2a.
So what we're gonna do now
is we're gonna implement
that a2a communication on top
of our agent Orchestrator.
And remember for the agent Orchestrator,
we are running the agent S2's patterns.
So we have an Orchestrator agent
that is calling other agent S2s.
So if you can see here,
we have just the
troubleshooting Kubernetes tools
that will trigger the
Kubernetes specialist agent.
What we're gonna do now
is we're gonna create the memory
agent two that we will talk
to the other agent running
its own server using a2a.
So the first thing that
we need to do is we need
to import the library that we want.
So a2a client tool provider.
And this way we are able to
use the other agent tools
in our own agent without
replicating those tools
in our code.
So this is the first
thing that we need to do.
Now another thing that we need
to do is actually create a tool,
since we're using the agent
S2s pattern from Strands,
we need to also create a tool
to talk to our memory agent.
So I'm gonna copy and paste the method
that we have created here.
And as you can see, I
have a decorator here.
So this is particular for Strands.
If you have the decorator
on top of the method,
you can use that method
S2s in your agent, right?
So that's the way that the method is able
to be identified as a tool.
But most important thing,
a2a client tool provider,
that comes from Strand.
And then I'm passing the memory agent URL,
if you can see here, port 9,000,
that's exactly the same
port that we have here
for the memory agent running as a server.
So we already have
configured that variable.
And then what I'm doing is,
I'm creating that agent here.
And this agent is just an interface.
So we are using this agent
to discover other agents
available in our environment.
In this case, we just
gave one single agent.
But if you look at here,
we have a list, we could pass
multiple different agents
and our agent would figure out
which agent it should call.
How many times I said agent right now?
(Sai chuckles)
Like 70 times.
- [Sai] I'm gonna say it
a couple more times too
'cause I think it might
be worth really quickly.
I'm gonna switch here to the
Strands agent architecture.
- Okay.
- Just to show you
what we did, right?
So we have that Orchestrator agent,
that's that big box over here
and it kind of is able
to discover all the other
tools it's able to work with.
So this external tool slash AWS,
that in itself can be additional agents.
That in itself is the kind
of swarm we're building here.
Strands likes to call it swarms,
but essentially it's all
of these different agents
that are discovering each
other and only talking to them
when they realize you need it.
And so I think that's really the idea here
is you can have all of
these different tools,
the MCP server that we
deployed, this memory agent,
and then we have this actual
Kubernetes Specialist agent.
And realistically,
it's hard for us to even
code like an if-else chain
of when which one should
talk to the other.
So we offload that
responsibility in itself
to an agent call.
- Shift to left,
remove from if-elses
and send to the agent.
- [Sai] Exactly. Exactly.
You got it. All right.
So let's get back to it
and see how you did it.
- [Lucas] Alright, so that's
the memory agent provider.
That's my tool that's gonna
talk to our agent server.
Last thing that we need to
do is we need to add that to-
To our-
- [Sai] You were saying earlier,
it's the agent S2, kind of paradigm.
That's essentially what we did.
We took an agent and we threw
it in there as another tool,
just like we did with MCP
and the troubleshooting step.
We just threw it in there.
- Yeah.
So if you look at Strands,
that's actually a pattern.
Agent S2, that's the pattern
that we are following.
And then we are adding a2a
on top of that as well.
So that's essentially what we are doing.
We have an orchestrator
agent that is responsible
to route requests to
other specialized agents.
So now let's go back,
I have added already the
memory agent provider here
as a tool.
So the last thing that
we need to do is we need
to change the system prompt.
So let's go to the
Orchestrator system prompt.
And then if you look at the system prompt,
we're not saying anything about memory
or vectors or whatever.
We're just saying like we have access
to that Kubernetes Specialist
agent to troubleshoot.
That's the one you have. Go for it.
Now what we are doing
is we're gonna replace
that Orchestrator assistant prompt
with something more
aligned to the memory agent
that we have created.
And for every agent we
have assistant prompt.
So in this case I'm saying,
"Hey, always check memory first
before doing any troubleshooting.
If you are not able to find memory,
then go and troubleshoot.
If the information is good enough,
then persist that information for me
after you're done with
the trouble shootings."
And again, we can control that.
We can split responsibilities here.
We can make the agent fix.
Of course, we don't want
to do that in production.
If we're talking about production,
we can make the agent open a pool request
for GitHub repository.
And we already have that.
If you want to see that come
back to next year code session.
But for this year code session,
we are doing an Orchestrator agent
and then just passing the prompt here.
So now I'm gonna do and
hopefully everything will work,
I'm gonna trigger our main
agent that's gonna be able
to talk to the other
agent running as a server.
- [Sai] So I see, now
you've started them up
as two separate processes.
- Two separate process.
- One for that memory agent,
one for the actual main
Orchestrator plus specialist.
And so think about this,
if you were to deploy this
in Kubernetes, for example,
you could deploy each of these
as individual Python pods
and also scale them independently
of one another as well.
For example, the memory agent has
to respond every single time
a message is pasted in Slack,
whereas the troubleshooting
agent doesn't need
to respond as often.
So you could really scale in
response to demand and load.
- [Lucas] Yeah.
So let's see if it actually works.
So what I'm gonna say
is I'm just gonna try
to trigger the agent to
persist a tip and advise
that some of our DevOps
engineers have done.
So what I'm gonna say is,
if you don't know how
much CPU and memory define
for your limits always
define the same as requests,
and that that might be true, right?
So, that's a tip that I'm giving
and I'm gonna say, tip from DevOps squad.
So hopefully we are gonna be
able to classify this message.
The agent should respond to this message
because it's related to troubleshooting.
Okay? As you can see-
- [Sai] Oh, we didn't fix
the classification, did we?
- [Lucas] We didn't
fix the classification.
- [Sai] That's right.
So the classification
should know, right now,
if you look at the prompt
for the classification model,
let's take a look at it really quickly.
If it's related
to Kubernetes system
troubleshooting technical issues,
I bet if we updated this and
let's make it a little smarter
of if you have any tips to store, right?
- Do you wanna do that?
- Let's do it.
- [Lucas] We haven't asked this.
- Let's try-
- Let's see if it-
I think it's gonna work.
Let's see, let's see.
Is this message related to Kubernetes
or request for help or any tips?
Is it good enough?
- Pretty good
- If it doesn't work,
I'm gonna tag the agent.
- [Sai] That should cover all the tips.
But you know, if we
wanted to get more precise
in the future for troubleshooting tips
or something like that, we could add that,
for now, we're doing it live.
We wanna make sure that
classification responds yes
for a message like that.
- If it doesn't respond yes,
then I can tag the agent
and you can be sure that
this is a live demo, right?
So let's wait for the
Kubernetes Specialist agent
and orchestrator agent
to start, there we go.
Now I'm gonna send
exactly the same message
and if we do it in the right way,
we should be able to see as-
- Come on, demo gods.
One time.
- Yes!
- [Sai] There we go. See?
So here's the thing again,
it is non-deterministic by nature.
That's how LLMs operate.
But you saw with just that
little bit of prodding
of like changing that
classification prompt,
we were able to make it respond better
for something like this.
And so we're not saying you're
gonna find the perfect prompt
that fits your use case immediately.
Like of course, for example,
OpenAI has been refining their prompts
and prompt engineering their
base models for years now.
You're gonna want to keep optimizing
and with that small optimization
the classification worked.
- [Lucas] And then if
you can see the agent,
they talk to each other.
So first we send a message
to discover the agents
that we have using the agent card
that is available in our agent.
So if you look at here,
we use it a2a list discovered agents,
and then we discovered a memory agent.
And then with this,
we also discovered the tools
that the agent that we
are talking to have.
And now, we are sending a
message to the right tool.
We send a message to store solution
in our other agent running as a server.
And if you can look at here,
we have one tool that was
called on the memory agent
that was to start a solution
related to QOS guaranteed.
Essentially, same amount of
CPU and memory resources.
And then, there you go,
you have a response here.
- [Sai] Okay.
And by the way,
I think in the real scenario
it wouldn't even respond,
the bot would just sit
there silently listening
for any tip and just
storing it in the database.
But for the sake of the demo,
we have it respond saying,
"Hey, this is a good tip,
we'll store it in the database."
- [Lucas] And if you're not trusting me,
we had one solution
before, let's refresh it.
Now we have a total of two solutions.
Let's search for CPU limits
and see if we have that solution
that are available already.
- [Sai] And so this is going directly
to the S3 vectors database, right?
Just looking at what solutions we have.
- [Lucas] Yeah, absolutely.
So that's the thing.
I'm doing a RAG here in the same way
that we are doing for the agent.
So we are like just retrieving,
embedding the query and then
retrieving the solution.
So that's the solution
with the shortest distance.
So essentially that's the
solution that means the most
for our use case right here.
So if you can see, please
define the same amount
of CPU and memory that
you have for your servers.
That's great.
- [Sai] It's like a
confidence rating, right?
It's like the inverse
of a confidence rating.
So smaller distance means more confident.
And I think you saw
that second solution was
at a distance of like 0.9,
that node exporter tip, not very relevant,
for the question that was
asked about CPU limits.
- [Lucas] Yeah.
So last thing that I'm gonna try to do,
I know that we have just five minutes.
So what I'm gonna try to do now
is I'm gonna deploy some failing pods.
And remember that first demo that we saw
before fixing the memory,
the monitoring agent,
that's essentially what
we're gonna try to do now.
So let me deploy the failing
pods through our cluster.
We should be able to see
the demo app namespace here.
- [Sai] And you still
have the Python main
orchestrator running right?
Or did we kill that?
- No, I killed that,
but I'm gonna make it run again.
- Okay, cool.
- But essentially,
we have the pods not running.
Let me just trigger the agent again.
Agentic troubleshooting
and then I'm gonna
trigger the agent again.
There you go.
So now if you look at this,
we have a lot of issues going on.
We have the monitoring agent not working,
we have the back end API restarting,
we out of memory queued, front
end has some issues as well.
And then we have a redis here.
Let's try to debug
and fix the monitoring agent
using the recommended image
that we have stored in the solutions.
So before we do that,
let's see if the agent
has it started already?
Both apps running. There you go.
So what I'm gonna say is,
"Hey folks, my monitoring
agent on demo-app namespace
is not running for some reason.
- You know, there's usually-
- I'm a developer,
I don't know why it's not running.
- [Sai] And you know,
there's usually some poor SRE
that's always in this
channel having to respond
to these kind of messages.
This guy who's probably
overloaded with too many messages,
maybe it's some of you
in this room can relate
to this yourself.
Hopefully the agent can pick
this up and not one of you,
right?
Love the emojis. Let's see.
- I just try
to see if it's gonna fail
or not but there you go.
Yes.
So the first thing that it's gonna do,
because our system prompt,
it's gonna search in our vector database
to see if there is any
solution related to this.
Hopefully we're gonna get the right image
because that's related to node exporter.
There it goes to the first
image, the first solution,
the closest one to what we
search is a solution number one.
So it was able to get in the proper way,
but it's not enough information.
So what the agent is doing
is actually doing the
troubleshooting by itself
with that information in mind.
If we had more information,
it would use it.
So I-
- [Sai] Actually love
this question you asked
because it just demonstrated
all the features we developed.
On the left side, it founded
two memory solutions.
It realized this isn't relevant.
Then it went back to the
original Specialist agent,
talks to MCP to get more
information about what's failing.
MCP gives it all the application
logs and the pod logs
and you can see it all thinking
all orchestrated together
and ideally figures out what
the original problem is.
- [Lucas] Yeah.
So right now it's just
storing the solution
because it was able to
find the root cause.
So if anyone deploys that agent again
with that same root cause,
we don't need to do the
troubleshooting again.
We can go straight to the issue.
So our solution-
- Wait,
that's actually really cool.
So it found the solution
and decided to store it
in our solutions database?
- Yeah.
- We didn't even have
to code that in there.
It realized it and decided
let's just store this
for future use.
- And if you look at this,
we didn't got the response
that we were expecting to get.
So, let's try to ask that again.
What is going on? What is the issue?
- [Sai] You know, we've seen this before,
when it stores the
solution in the database,
it considers itself done.
It's like, "Found a solution, stored it."
We don't have to respond, there you go.
There you go.
- But since we have,
we still have the context on
the threads and everything,
it responded super fast.
So essentially the root cause is,
you are using the image,
nonexistent monitoring agent dot latest.
Of course this image doesn't exist.
So would you like me to guide you
to the steps to fix the issue?
No, I would like you to fix the issue.
So I'm gonna say k8s magic bot, please,
because you said that you
don't want me to add please.
I'm gonna say please
because I still, I watch
a terminator number two.
So I'm gonna say please.
So please, can you fix
the monitoring agent
for me using the recommended DevOps?
Oops. DevOps image?
- Okay, while this thing Lucas.
'cause we have 15 seconds left folks,
I wanna share with you some
resources really quickly.
So scan this QR code, it's
gonna take you to a GitHub
of all of the container sessions
that we're doing at reinvent.
So find our session here.
So with CNS421,
find our session and we'll
have the sample code,
we'll have all of the code
that we showed today linked
as well.
It's all on GitHub for you to go through.
We really appreciate you
spending your time here
with us today.
So scan that QR,
you'll find all of the
relevant resources there
and we would love for you
to leave us some feedback
in the app as well.
Thank you so much.
- Hold on, hold on,
hold on, hold hold, hold on.
Can you go back to the demo?
There it goes.
So now we have the
monitoring agent running
as you can see right there.
And then if we go to alert
managers, there we go, it's over.
(audience clapping)
Same deal.
We deserve it.
Thank you. Thank you so much.